aujourd'hui six ans jacob bonjour c'est
vrai c'est pas simple on va en parler ce
matin vous voyez affluer les demandes
d'adhésion pour le prochain congrès on
le sait vous espérer atteindre combien
de votants
dont on verra il ya
depuis
quatre ans nous avions une baisse très
important du nombre de militants depuis
l'année dernière
non seulement stoppé la baisse est
remonté je pense qu'il y aura à la fin
de l'année vraisemblablement plus de
plus de cent mille militants encartés au
palace était de voter pour le losc ce
qui veut dire par rapport aux prévisions
qu'on aurait pu faire en début d'année à
peu près 15 % de plus est-ce que valérie
pécresse et xavier bertrand ont déjà
pris leur carte est ce que c'est fait
vraiment au jeu penche oui je prends
soin vue oui
d'abord montchamp je suis ravi oui
j'ai fait partie de ceux
qui leur avaient vertement c'était une
erreur de partir donc on va pas leur
dire c'est une erreur de revenir
aujourd'hui c'est une très bonne chose
une très bonne chose que la famille soit
rassemblée ça n'était pas nécessairement
facile pour eux mais je suis ravi qu'il
soit là et c'est la famille de droite
rassemblée au conquet
fumer le calumet le calumet de la paix
avant la bataille en général c'est après
qu'on le fait qu'elle engagement a été
pris lors de ce petit déjeuner de cette
rencontre entre tous les candidats
d'abord dans un très bon état d'esprit
la démonstration qu'on vient de faire
depuis deux ans vous savez d'où on vient
on a perdu deux présidentielles de suite
de législatives de suite une défaite des
plus cinglantes aux élections
européennes mais depuis deux ans les
républicains gagnent toutes les
élections sans aucune exception on a
remporté une victoire sans précédent aux
municipales aux sénatoriales au
départemental aux régionales maintenant
on et voilà sur la dernière ligne droite
qui est celle des présidentielles et on
a gagné comment toutes ces élections
précédentes à chaque fois en étant dans
l'unité dans l'union et dans le
rassemblement et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaitais que tout le monde
soit le problème c'est que ça vous a pas
échappé et que ils vont essayer de se
départager les uns les autres c'est ça
le principe d'une compétition c'est une
compétition ce congrès que le meilleur
gagne que la meilleure gagne c'est un
processus de sélection mais bien de
pièges oui ce que je veux dire est ce
que vous voyez arriver y aura des débats
d'ailleurs inra sur france 2 le dernier
le décisif le 30 novembre avec nos
partenaires également de france inter
quand on va organiser des débats avec
thomas sotto à léa salamé lorsque
lorsqu'on organise des débats comme
comme cela le ris jaune rice un stand je
sais que vous allez de sympathiques avec
nos candidats et toi bien se passer pas
le contraire
mais là comment on arrivé là on a fait
tout ce travail au delà des victoires
électorales que j'évoquais à l'instant
encore une fois c'est très rare qu'un
parti en chaîne autant de victoires en
deux ans nous avons fait un travail de
fond avec un projet qui aujourd'hui sur
la table projet dans lequel tous nos
candidats se retrouvent alors après bien
évidemment chacun y met son tempérament
sa personne
jacob voleur avait dit attention
attention il ya un piège il faut pas
tomber dans ce piège là avec des débats
qui mettra en scène des divisions une
rivalité je soupçonne qu'ils n'avaient
pas besoin que je leur dise je pense
qu'à l'heure était venue à l'esprit
parce qu'ils savent tous que on ne gagne
que dans le rassemblement et l'unité et
et quand on apprend encore une fois
enchaîné des défaites comme on les a
enchaîné précédemment on connaît les
germes de la division on sait que la
division pousse à l'échec et tout le
monde aujourd'hui unanimement tous nos
candidats ont bien conscience que c'est
dans l'unité dans le rassemblement ce
qui empêche pas de marquer ses
différences parce que bien entendu vous
les connaissez clients ils ont des
personnalités différentes
des sujets sur lesquels ils sont plus
sensibles les uns que les autres mais le
socle idéologique de la droite été
rebâti par le travail de fond nous avons
réalisé pendant deux ans d'ailleurs vous
entendez plus de questions sur la ligne
mais où la ligne des républicains ce
sujet tranché havane où il été tranchée
par les médias sans cesse qu'il ait
tranché se marrent posait
figaro je pense que vous l'avez lu eric
ciotti propose qui est candidat lui
aussi propose d'instaurer une sorte de
préférence nationale et communautaires
européennes sur l'emploi les allocations
logement aucune aide au retraitement des
urgences vitales ne sera accordée à un
étranger en situation irrégulière
la préférence nationale c'était réservé
à la droite nationale ce que nous avons
dit sur ce sujet nous avons un vrai
sujet sur l'immigration l'immigration
incontrôlée et non mais attendez
tout le monde mesure bien aujourd'hui
que nous avons un certain nombre de
personnes qui migrent en france pour
pouvoir bénéficier des aides et donc
l'idée là dessus et de recadrer les
choses et de dire que par exemple pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'une allocation ou
d'une aide eh bien il faut avoir cotisé
un certain nombre d'années et ça c'est
dans notre projet quelque chose qui a
compté dix préférence nationale par
exemple pour l'emploi pour le logement
c'est pas dans votre projet mort bien
sûr mais après chaque camp non parce que
je le chante et ça chaque candidat va
plus loin c'est le choix d'eric ciotti
nous nous avons un
chéquier clair encore une fois sur le
fait de dire faisons attention à ces
systèmes qui qui amène des gens qui
pensent découvrir l' eldorado en france
en fait il le découvre pas et qui sont
atterrés pas par des amériques normes et
après je si vous le connaissez on a
construit
[Musique]
par face à la droite de votre vexé on a
un socle et la droite les diverses la
droite elle a toujours été vous savez
c'est ce fameux trépied des gaullistes
qu'on appelait bonapartiste avant des
libéraux et des démocrates chrétiens et
donc chacun sa sensibilité est franchie
par son jeu non il est sur ce qu'il a
souvent incarné dans notre dans notre
famille politique
eric ciotti et plus le pas le plus
centriste chez nous mais au-delà de cela
le socle idéologique l'été projet après
alors chacun joue dans son important
parce que vous savez qu'on va parler
dans un instant d'eric zemmour vous
considérez qu'il ne franchit pas une
ligne rouge pour les valeurs qu'incarne
votre part les partisans de la
préférence nationale pour l'emploi
entouré aux allocations pour le logement
après roger après regardons ce qu'il met
derrière et de dire aujourd'hui que les
allocations doivent être réservées à
ceux qui cotisent qui paye et qui
travaillent
c'est ce que nous avons dit dans notre
projet nous avons travaillé dessus
c'était voter parano nous militants très
très largement ce qui n'empêche pas les
capacités d'accueil ce qui n'empêche pas
d'intervenir dans les cas d'urgence
d'ailleurs c'est ce que eric ciotti des
également est-ce que vous pensez que le
candidat qui va sortir de ce congrès
bénéficiera d'une dynamique même si
c'était un congrès international inc que
c'est ce que vous souhaitez je suis
courageux plus oui je suis con ça va
donner une dynamique au candidat que
c'était bien évidemment bien évidemment
parce que ça va nous donner l'occasion
et c'est pour ça que je vais pas vous
souhaitez que l'on mélange des élections
c'est à dire que lorsqu'on était dans
les régionales on s'est occupé des
régionales et départementales
en l'occurrence que c'était le même jour
et nous sommes passés ensuite aux
élections nationales nous sommes
maintenant en route en direction de la
présidentielle donc avec le projet avec
la décision du choix de notre candidat
est bien évidemment une dynamique va se
créer à partir du 5 décembre et on la
retrouvera à partir de la deuxième
quinzaine de missions est ce que vous
reconnaissez christian jacob que la
dynamique elle est du côté d'eric
zemmour
nomique médiatique avant le reste mais
oui parce que vous savez s'il
six mois avant vous savez pertinemment
que les français ne sont pas dans
l'élection présidentielle et il ya une
tradition avec la vème république sait
que la période de l'automne période on
identifie les candidats et la campagne
vous le savez pertinemment elle
démarrera après les cérémonies de voeux
et c'est totalement serein vis-à-vis de
duca zemmour d'écouté oui parce que nous
nous sommes sur notre couloir donc
bon le connais bien c'est un polémiste
il est dans l'incantation sa vie
justement vous parlez de provocation
grave à votre ami christian jacob quand
il tourne une arme non chargée vers les
journalistes est ce que vous vous
offusquez comme marlène schiappa kitsch
à pâques et dit c'est très grave ou est
ce que vous nous dites il faut pas
tomber dans ce piège en gros quelle est
la bonne stratégie jeudi j'ai écouté
j'ai vu cette image dit que c'est un
geste totalement irresponsable oui moi
je suis un chasseur toujours assumé j'ai
mon permis de chasse à 16 ans j'ai 61
ans je n'ai pas rater une saison de
chasse j'ai fait mon service militaire
j'ai été responsable d'armures et donc
le maniement des armes j'en ai certaine
expérience jamais jamais en aucune
condition une arme soit réelle ou
factice on ne porte le canon en
direction de quelqu'un gc une oreille il
dit célibat c'est pas de l'humour c'est
irresponsable
on ne le fait pas dès que si vous êtes
en face de quelqu'un qui sait ce que
c'est que le maniement des armes jamais
jamais jamais on ne fait quelle est la
bonne stratégie vis-à-vis d'eric zemmour
il faut lui répondre soulignons il faut
être sur sa ligne nous nous avons
travaillé encore une fois sur le
régalien soit les aspects économiques
sur le social la droit d'occuper tout
l'espace qui est le sien et on va pas se
préoccuper chaque jour des provocations
direction gavray dois tu sais moi et je
veux une droite qui ne se renie pas qui
ne baisse pas la tête je regarde la
glace tous les matins un peu d'humilité
ne nuit pas non plus pour réguler un mot
sur nicolas sarkozy benjamin blanchet
qui préside l'audience du procès des
sondages de l'elysée a demandé la venue
nicolas sarkozy si besoin par la force
est ce que ça vous a choqué là aussi
vous parler enfin je veux dire on est
non seulement dans l'acharnement
monsieur le juge je trouve ça mesquin
déplacés enfin moi je suis choqué par
tout cela est objectivement je ne suis
pas convaincu que tout cela donne une
belle image de la justice
merci beaucoup